es ist der Moment der alles verändert
das tödliche Beben in der Türkei Anfang
Februar
10.000 Menschen sterben fast zwei
Millionen verlieren wir zu Hause es ist
alles eigentlich stürzt
ich habe immer noch große Angst
erst kommen Schock und Trauer dann kommt
die Wut der Staat versagt die Hilfen
erreichen die Gegenden nicht es ist
alles schlecht organisiert
von Normalität bis heute keine Spur
Leben im Ausnahmezustand
die Menschen sind fast alle weggegangen
die Orte sind völlig leer
im Mai wählen die Türken eine Abstimmung
auch über das Krisenmanagement von
Präsident Erdogan der lockt im Wahlkampf
mit großen Versprechen
unser Ziel ist es den größten Teil der
Häuser für die Erdbebenopfer innerhalb
eines Jahres wieder aufzubauen
doch der Widerstand gegen Erdogan wächst
zu groß ist bei vielen die Wut nach dem
Beben
[Musik]
wir sind in eskenderun wichtige Hafen
und Handelsstadt am Mittelmeer im Süden
der Türkei
vor dem Beben zählte die Stadt 250.000
Einwohner wie viele jetzt noch hier sind
wie viele Tod oder verletzt das kann uns
niemand sagen
überall Trümmer Zerstörung Chaos auch
Wochen nach dem Beben
[Musik]
im Stadtzentrum treffen wir Elif das
Beben hat das Leben der Elfjährigen für
immer verändert
[Musik]
weil das Haus zerstört ist lebt sie
jetzt in einem Container vier Familien
schlafen hier
es ist wirklich schwer wir treten uns
gegenseitig auf die Füße wenn wir
aufstehen müssen um auf die Toilette zu
gehen
elef lächelt immer sie lächelt das
Trauma einfach weg
und doch sind sie sich nach ein bisschen
Normalität
wenn du dir was wünschen könntest was
wäre das im Moment
ich werde mir eine Wohnung wünschen
meine Schule und einen Ort wo wir leben
können
ich würde mir ein eigenes Zimmer
wünschen und ich würde mir wünschen
meinem Vater die Tür öffnen zu können
wenn er von der Arbeit zurückkommt
ich würde mir eine Küche wünschen wo ich
mit meiner Mutter Kekse backen kann
dass wir einen schönen Ort zum Leben
haben
zum ersten Mal treffen wir Elif wenige
Tage nach dem Leben schon damals Haus
die Familie gemeinsam mit Verwandten auf
engstem Raum
Elis Eltern gehört ein Umzugsunternehmen
sie schlafen in einem der LKW
wir sind hier bis zu 12 Personen wir
schlafen dicht an dich
als die Erde bebte hat ihre Mutter elef
fest im Arm gehalten für eine lange
schreckliche Minute sie haben Glück
gehabt überlebt aber Glück das ist
Dennis Kennerin relativ Schock am
meisten traurig um meine früheren
Nachbarn
einige Freunde meiner Tochter um die
traurig ich trauere um die Schule um
ihre Ausbildung um unser Haus
ja meine Trauer ist groß aber ich
versuche zu lächeln für die Kinder wir
versuchen weiterzuleben
das Erdbeben hat die Familie wie so
viele im Schlaf überrascht als sie
versuchten zu fliehen ließ sich die
Haustür nicht öffnen in Panik sprangen
sie aus dem Fenster konnten sich über
den Garten ins Freie retten
ich habe sehr viel Angst gehabt wir
lebten im mittleren Gebäude von drei
Häusern es hat sehr stark gewackelt es
hat sich so angefühlt als würde das Haus
jeden Moment einstürzen
ich zeige elef die Bilder von damals
viel hat sich seitdem nicht für sie
verändert
Essen und Wasser bekommt die Familie bei
den Hilfsorganisationen
die Schule ist bis zum 27 mai
geschlossen auch wenn kein Unterricht
stattfindet werde ich trotzdem hingehen
ich möchte meine Freunde sehen und
fragen wie es Ihnen geht zum Glück ist
die Schule nicht eingestürzt
die elfjährige Elif
Freunde treffen Unterricht die Kinder
von Iskenderun warten sehnlichst darauf
die Erdbebenkatastrophe lässt sich fast
in Echtzeit miterleben
nach dem Beben tauchen im Internet
unzählige Handyvideos auf dokumentieren
das Ausmaß der Zerstörung
[Musik]
doch immer wieder gibt es auch Momente
der Hoffnung Menschen die entgegen aller
Wahrscheinlichkeit aus den Trümmern
gerettet werden
[Musik]
denn es kennaron erleben wir vor allem
eins Fassungslosigkeit wie haben sie
dieses Erdbeben erlebt
das Erdbeben kann man nicht beschreiben
man kann es nicht erzählen und wirklich
sogar jetzt noch habe ich sehr große
Angst
ich habe eine sehr große Angst durchlebt
ich kann es nicht erzählen
in der Nacht so gegen 4 Uhr sind wir vom
Erdbeben geweckt worden plötzlich lagen
wir unter den Trümmern drei Stunden
meine Verlobte und ich haben uns dann
aus eigener Kraft befreien können mein
Fuß wurde eingequetscht an meinem Arm
habe ich eine große Wunde
[Musik]
aber auch damals schon immer mehr Wut
warum kam die Hilfe in der Provinz
hathai so spät an Hatay wird behandelt
wie ein Stiefkind die Hilfen erreichen
die Gegenden nicht es ist alles schlecht
organisiert
während wir mit unseren Händen nach
Überlebenden suchen fahren andere hier
mit ihren Baggern über die Menschen und
zerquetschen sie
tatsächlich gibt es seit dem Beben
heftige Kritik am Katastrophenmanagement
der Regierung Erdogan sogar von
Staatsversagen ist die Rede
die meisten Helfer die wir direkt nach
dem Beben treffen sind freiwillige viele
sind auch aus den großen Städten wie
Istanbul gekommen und bei den
Rettungsarbeiten zu helfen oder Essen zu
verteilen von den großen türkischen
Hilfsorganisationen wie der
Katastrophenschutzbehörde Abfahrt oder
dem Roten Halbmond kommt wenig zu spät
zu unkoordiniert so der Vorwurf
kritiker sehen die Schuld auch bei ihm
dem Generaldirektor des
Katastrophenschutzes Abfahrt Ismael
palacolo der Theologe ist zwar eng
vernetzt mit Erdogan Vorerfahrungen im
Katastrophenschutz hat er aber nicht
sowohl bei Abfahrt wie auch beim Roten
Halbmond gab es keine Führungskräfte mit
der nötigen Qualifikation oder genug
Erfahrung
das zeigt dass es in der Türkei eine
Willkür Herrschaft gibt
so hat özilippy ist Politikberater und
hat schon für verschiedene Parteien
Wahlkampagnen geleitet das größte
Problem beim Katastrophenmanagement
sieht er bei Erdogan selbst in seinem
Präsidialsystem müsse jede Entscheidung
von ganz oben abgesegnet werden
dieser Fehler wurde uns bei diesem
Erdbeben direkt vor Augen geführt
hätten die örtlichen zuständigen die
nötigen Entscheidungsbefugnisse gehabt
wäre der Verlust an Menschenleben nicht
so hoch gewesen
[Musik]
eine jahrhundert-katastrophe ganz so als
ob seine Regierung keine Schuld treffe
auch nicht am Krisenmanagement
erst bei einem ortsbesuch drei Wochen
nach dem Beben so etwas wie ein Schuld
Eingeständnis
wegen des schlechten Wetters und der
beschädigten Straßen
ist es uns während der ersten Tage nicht
gelungen unsere Arbeit in adiamant so zu
machen wie wir wollten
dafür bitte ich um verzeihen
an der Stimmung im Erdbebengebiet ändert
die später Einsicht wenig weit
verbreitet das Gefühl vergessen worden
zu sein
[Musik]
wir machen uns auf den Weg nach elbistan
die Stadt in den Bergen wurde vor allem
vom zweiten schweren Beben am 6 Februar
stark zerstört
ganz in der Nähe lag das Epizentrum
[Musik]
und seine Familie haben überlebt sie
haben zwar alles verloren aber als wir
ihn treffen gibt es erst einmal Tee
Gastfreundschaft trotz Katastrophe
uns geht es gut man arrangiert sich ich
habe es mir nicht so sehr zu Herzen
genommen aber meine Frau Dilek ist sehr
traurig sie ist psychisch belastet und
wird derzeit in England behandelt sie
hat gesehen wie die Gebäude eingestürzt
sind das hat sie nicht gut verkraftet
ist Geschäftsmann verkauft
landwirtschaftliche Produkte wie Dünger
und Pflanzenschutzmittel
sein Laden steht noch auch wenn die
Spuren des Bebens deutlich sichtbar sind
auch Familie ist Dill haben wir schon
einmal getroffen direkt nach der
Katastrophe schon beim Beben in der
Nacht hat es bei ihnen so stark
gewackelt dass der Sohn aus dem Bett
gefallen ist das zweite Beben bei dem so
viele starben weil sie in den Häusern
noch Sachen retten wollten haben die SDS
im Freien verbracht
in dem Moment als das zweite Beben kam
waren meine Frau und ich zufällig
draußen der Asphalt hat sich hoch und
runter bewegt wie eine Welle im Wasser
und sämtliche Gebäude kippen
nacheinander um wie Dominosteine entlang
der ganzen Straße vor unseren Augen sind
sie umgefallen in nur wenigen Sekunden
alle zusammengestürzt
36 Stunden dauert es bis die ersten
offiziellen Rettungsteams elbestan
erreichen davor haben Sie hier mit
bloßen Händen versucht Verschüttete zu
retten die bei eisigen Minusgraden unter
den Trümmern liegen dann übernehmen die
Rettungsteams bitten immer wieder um
Stille damit sie hören können ob noch
Rufe aus den Trümmern kommen
Leslie Hahn hat am Morgen noch ihren
Mann unter den Trümmern gehört doch die
Rufe sind verstummt und Neslihan ahnt
dass sie jede Hoffnung wohlauf geben
muss
das war unser Haus und da drin ist mein
Mann
ich kann nicht reden ich kann nicht
ich habe niemanden ich bin ganz allein
[Musik]
Leid und Verzweiflung überall
gegenüber haben syrische Flüchtlinge
gewohnt der Leichnam eines
Familienvaters wird geborgen und einfach
auf der Straße abgelegt die
Rettungsteams müssen weitermachen die
Angehörigen des 46-Jährigen stehen
hilflos daneben völlig allein gelassen
immer wieder hören wir auch hier die Wut
der Überlebenden
habt ihr denn überhaupt schon Hilfe
bekommen
es ist alles eigentlich stürzt die Leute
sind in den gestürzten Häusern erfroren
es wird nicht geholfen ist geht in Elvis
dann überhaupt nichts gemacht
die Frau von Geschäftsmann jebrail lange
hat sie in Österreich gelebt der Schock
über das Geschehene macht sie ratlos
repariert werden und wie soll das gehen
es ist schrecklich es ist wirklich
schrecklich unsere Freunde sind tot wir
weinen nur noch was sollen wir machen
ich habe mein ganzes Haus verloren
unsere Büro ist kaputt unser Haus ist
kaputt wir sind jetzt nur noch mit zwei
Einkaufstaschen unterwegs
drei Wochen nach dem Beben treffen wir
dilexmann-gebrail wieder er lebt jetzt
bei seinen Eltern in einem Dorf in der
Nähe das Beben sagt jebrail habe
elbistan die Zukunft genommen
[Musik]
oder ein economy die Wirtschaft hier
wird lange Zeit brauchen um sich zu
erholen von den 110.000 Einwohner von
elvistan sind jetzt nur noch 10.000
übrig die Menschen sind fast alle
weggegangen die Orte sind völlig leer
normalerweise sagt er hätte Elvis da
noch solch eine Katastrophe überstehen
können
schließlich könne man erdbebensicher
bauen auch in der Türkei
ohne Pfusch am Bau ohne die übliche
Korruption
dieses Gebäude da drüben ist neu damit
gibt es kein Problem aber das andere da
ist alt die werden einfach aufgestockt
so dass es fünf oder sechs Etagen sind
das ist illegal diese Gebäude stürzen
dann ein
dabei hatte die Türkei ihre Lektion
eigentlich gelernt nach dem verheerenden
Erdbeben 99 nahe Istanbul hatte das Land
deutlich strengere Bauvorschriften
erlassen auf dem Papier gut nur wurden
die oft nicht eingehalten
das liegt auch an der Regierung von
Präsident Erdogan der hat die
Bauindustrie weitgehend frei agieren
lassen wichtige Bau- und
Infrastrukturprojekte sichern auch seine
Macht die Bauaufsicht hat der Staat
dagegen immer mehr in private Hände
gegeben die Kontrollen sind unzureichend
ein Wirtschaftsbereich durchsetzt von
Korruption
beim Bausektor traten die engen
Beziehungen zwischen Regierung und
Bauunternehmern und dem Kapital was da
geflossen ist sehr deutlich zu Tage wir
sind Zeuge dessen geworden dass
Bauunternehmen die der Regierung nahe
standen in Gebieten gebaut haben die
normalerweise gar kein Baugrund sind
eine dieser Siedlungen ist bei dem
Erdbeben jetzt eingestürzt
und das ist nicht der einzige Vorwurf
gegen Erdogans Regierung völlig unklar
auch wo die Milliarden Einnahmen aus
einer erdbeben-steuer versickert sind
die eigentlich in den Erdbebenschutz
investiert werden sollten dabei waren
Experten seit Jahrzehnten davor das
nächste große Beben in der Türkei sei
nur eine Frage der Zeit
zuletzt hat auch die Architektenkammer
der Regierung große mit Schuld am Ausmaß
der Katastrophe gegeben 2018 ließ
Erdogan hunderttausende illegal gebaute
Häuser gegen eine Gebühren nachträglich
legalisieren statt die Gebäude
abzureißen oder zumindest gründlich zu
prüfen nahm der Staat lieber Geld und
drückte dafür ein Auge zu
was Erdogan vor den Wahlen 2018 Stimmen
der Hausbesitzer sicherte dürfte jetzt
tausende Leben gekostet haben
das hat sechs Milliarden Lira in die
Kassen gespült der damalige Minister hat
gesagt dass sie die bauamnestie erlassen
damit man die Häuser mit dem Geldern
erdbebensicher machen kann nachdem man
sie erst einmal legalisiert hat diese
Gelder sollten an die Stadtverwaltungen
gehen aber nichts davon ist passiert
Erdogan selbst will von diesen Vorwürfen
nichts wissen stattdessen lassen seine
Behörden seit dem Beben demonstrativ
dutzende Bauunternehmer festnehmen und
geben Ihnen die alleinige Schuld ganz so
als hätten Erdogan und seine Politik
damit nichts zu tun
[Musik]
wir fahren nach adiaman auch die 270.000
Einwohner Stadt im Südosten der Türkei
wurde hart vom Beben getroffen
das Stadtzentrum weitestgehend
die historische Uhr mit dem Adler zeigt
immer noch 4:17 Uhr an die Zeit als das
erste schwere Beben die Region
erschütterte
die Überlebenden von adiamant wollen
nicht mehr warten sie helfen sich selbst
auch wenn das oft lebensgefährlich ist
überall sehen wir Umzugswagen vor völlig
zerstörten Häusern Menschen die durch
offene Hausfassaden ihre Besitztümer
retten das einzige was ihnen geblieben
ist
als alles zusammenbrach sind wir
runtergerannt ich bin mit meinem Kind
rückwärts aus dem zweiten Stock gestürzt
Gott sei Dank sind wir auf einer weichen
Stelle gelandet sonst wäre ich
wahrscheinlich tot
dass die Möbel Rettungsaktion gefährlich
ist
schon aber in ihrer Not sehen viele hier
keine andere Möglichkeit
was sollen wir machen wir versuchen es
eben mit unseren eigenen Mitteln
eigentlich warten wir auf den
Katastrophenschutz Erfurt aber bis jetzt
sind sie nicht gekommen
im Stadtzentrum treffen wir Jascha Ei er
ist im Auftrag der Regierung unterwegs
und prüft welche Häuser noch bewohnbar
sind welche abgerissen werden müssen
mehr als einen Hammer hat Jascha Ei dazu
nicht er verteidigt diese eher einfache
Methode
überall auf der Welt macht man das so
mit einem Hammer und dann schauen wir
nach das ist eine international
anerkannte Methode andere gibt es nicht
in die Häuser darf er nicht
stellt er von außen Risse in tragenden
Säulen fest werden die Gebäude
abgerissen ein riskanter Job auch wegen
der vielen Nachbeben was soll ich tun
wir müssen die Gefahr auf uns nehmen für
unser Volk es ist unsere Pflicht dieses
Opfer zu bringen Sie keine Angst
es gibt keine Angst allah sei Dank er
ist mit uns
der türkische Staat mache in dieser
Situation alles richtig erzählt uns
Jascha ein
für sein Land wünscht sich der glühende
Erdogan Anhänger vor allem Frieden und
Zusammenhalt
möge Allah unser Land verunruhen
schützen und möge er uns immer unseren
Präsidenten taip Erdogan erhalten
das sehen Sie in einem provisorischen
Zeltlager am Stadtrand völlig anders die
Mehrheit der Bewohner von adiaman sind
Kurden Aleviten die Zeltstadt bauen
freiwilliger auf viele stehen der Pro
kurdischen Oppositionspartei HDP nach
die erhebt schwere Vorwürfe der Staat
Behinderte die Arbeit von Freiwilligen
und schaffe es nicht selbst für
ausreichend Hilfe zu sorgen
das System möchte nicht dass die
Freiwilligen dieser Arbeit machen
es sieht uns als eine Alternative an und
ist geschockt
weil man nicht will dass das Volk sieht
wie das staatliche System zusammenbricht
obdachlos gewordene Familien sollen hier
Schutz finden sogar einen Kindergarten
betreiben sie
wollen denen etwas bieten die in der
Katastrophe oft vergessen werden
wir versuchen überall wo es geht
Spielplätze einzurichten damit wollen
wir den Kindern helfen ihre
traumatischen Erfahrungen zu verarbeiten
die kinder sind neugierig auf uns
erzählen uns vom Projekt
es ist schön
wie findest du das dass es hier
Spielzeug gibt
ich finde es auch schön
heironisa und Osman wollen uns zeigen
wie sie leben
sie führen uns zu einem der Zelte nach
dem Beben hat ihre Familie zunächst eine
Woche im Auto übernachtet jetzt sind sie
hier untergekommen Schlafen zu fünft auf
provisorischen Betten
[Musik]
wir haben so viel durchgemacht mein
Onkel meine Tante und die Tochter meiner
Tante sind beim Erdbeben gestorben meine
Nachbarn sind gestorben meine Wohnung
ist schwer beschädigt jetzt sind wir
hilflos mit all unseren Kindern was
sollen wir machen es ist Schicksal
hier finden die Menschen zumindest
vorübergehend eine Bleibe bekommen
Wasser Essen Kleidung falls die
türkischen Behörden das überhaupt
zulassen
selbst bei kleinsten Angelegenheiten
stellt man sich uns in den Weg
wir wollen dass wir frei arbeiten können
wir machen hier keine politische Arbeit
wir wollen nur den Erdbebenopfern helfen
im alevitischen Kulturzentrum in adiaman
hören wir diese Vorwürfe auch von
hdp-abgeordneten hier gehen die
Befürchtungen sogar noch weiter die AKP
von Präsident Erdogan könne das Erdbeben
dafür nutzen die bevorstehenden Wahlen
zu manipulieren
die Frage der Durchführung von Wahlen
ist in der Tat umstritten denn die
Bevölkerung von adiaman nimmt ab viele
Menschen verlassen das Erdbebengebiet
deshalb könnte es bei den Wahlen zu
einer Täuschung kommen denn die
erdbebenprovinzen sind leer
Mitte Mai stehen in der Türkei
präsidentschafts- und Parlamentswahlen
an es wird auch eine Abstimmung über das
Krisenmanagement der Regierung Erdogan
der Präsident versucht noch einmal alles
um bei den Wählern zu punkten bei einem
Besuch in adiaman verteilt Erdogan sogar
Geldscheine an Kinder umgerechnet 10 €
und er macht große Versprechen für den
Wiederaufbau
unser Ziel ist es den größten Teil der
Häuser für die Erdbeben Opfer innerhalb
eines Jahres fertig zu stellen
hunderttausende Häuser wieder aufbauen
in nur einem Jahr dazu auch noch
erdbebensicher
beobachter halten das für völlig
unrealistisch
innerhalb eines Jahres den Wiederaufbau
zu schaffen das kann nur Erdogan
gelingen so soll das Motto seiner
Wahlkampagne sein dadurch versucht
Erdogan die Zweifel an seine Person die
durch die Katastrophe entstanden sind in
Zuspruch umzuwandeln
die Wut über Erdogans Krisenmanagement
wird zuletzt auch öffentlich sichtbar im
Fußballstadion von Besiktas Istanbul
werfen Anhänger reihenweise Kuscheltiere
auf den Rasen zum Gedenken an die Kinder
die im Erdbebengebiet ums Leben kamen
auf den Rängen fordern Fans den
Rücktritt der Regierung
[Musik]
die reagiert sofort wer mitgesungen hat
und per Video identifiziert werden kann
bei dem klopft die Polizei an die
Konsequenz Stadionverbot auch mehrere
regierungskritische Internetseiten
werden gesperrt
Wähler Umfragen zeigen eine Abwahl von
dauerherscher Erdogan ist diesmal
tatsächlich möglich zwar sind viele noch
unentschieden aber das Erdbeben hat den
Präsidenten geschadet
ist dass Erdbeben hatte einen schlechten
Einfluss auf die Popularität des Herrn
Präsidenten es hat seine Inkompetenz in
einigen Bereichen offengelegt besonders
beim Katastrophenmanagement hat die
Regierung sehr schwere Fehler gemacht
zurück bei Geschäftsmann Greil östil
erst nach dem Beben in elbistan
geblieben trotz aller Zerstörung seine
Frau hat es hier nicht mehr ausgehalten
wir rufen Sie an um zu hören wie sie die
Katastrophe verkraftet hat
aber jetzt bist du bei Verwandten in
England
[Musik]
ich bleibe noch ein bisschen hier bis
ich mich an diese Tabletten gewöhnt habe
und dann komme ich wieder zurück ich
muss hier wieder zurück kommen
Antidepressiva um mittag-katastrophe
leben zu können trotzdem wollen die erst
jetzt in Elvis tan bleiben das hier sei
ihre Heimat sagt jebrail ihr gesamtes
Leben sei hier auch wenn es Jahre dauern
dürfte bis die Stadt sich wieder erholt
das ist wie ein Krieg
als ob wir Bomben abbekommen haben
so wie Deutschland sich aus den Trümmern
erhoben hat so werden wir es auch
schaffen
die Türkei nach dem Erdbeben Wut und
Verzweiflung darüber dass der Staat so
zögerlich reagiert hat
dass seine verfehlte Politik und aktives
wegschauen bei den Baubehörden so viele
Häuser zu Todesfallen gemacht haben
das Ignoranz Korruption und
Staatsversagen die Katastrophe
verschlimmert haben
all das könnte die Wahlen im Mai
entscheidend beeinflussen die Folgen des
schweren Erdbebens werden die Türkei für
Jahre prägen
[Musik]